fedict un bon soir c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup de plaisir à retrouver dans ce
disque il ya une aspiration bob marley
iéna situation africaine et puis un
mélange de choses que vous avez acquises
en en chemin je dirais voit le métissage
ou à travers les voyages forcément j'ai
toujours gardé le souvenir de mon
enfance en afrique et rapport très fort
avec la jamaïque et bob marley et puis
bale et les textes en français parce que
parce que ma mois et française et que
j'ai dépassé la plus grand que certaines
que jusqu'à présent c'était un anglais
donc il ya une sorte de ont franchi un
cap
on va plus près du public présent mais
on avance s'était pas acquis au départ
au début chanter pour le comme ça pour
le fun et puis après j'ai voulu chanter
mes chansons et puis c'est vrai que
entre le moment où je chantais des
chansons des autres iron man a fait
chanter les miennes mais il a fallu
s'ouvrir un peu et je crois qu'il ya pas
mal de pudeur je crois que vous cachez
un petit peu vain derrière la langue
l'anglais s'il y avoir un petit peu de
ça et puis en plus j'avais pas le le
luxe mais l'opportunité de chanter des
textes fait pour moi par des parts des
tout bons mais je vais proposer une
impression en écoutant et en beaucoup de
l'écoutant avec plaisir y est vous êtes
très à l'aise dans tous les coûts
d'impression vous êtes un une sorte de
plénitude dans ses textes ses musiques
vous retrouver pleinement la wii c'est
une recherche car kutcher c'est vrai que
trouver vraiment sa tonalité sa façon
d'exprimer certaines émotions sa façon
de deux connus communiquer à travers le
chant ça m'a pris du temps et
la whey je me sens je me sens à l'aise
tous à l'aise parce que j'aime les
textes
je me sens bien avec les textes je me
suis emparé de ces musiques laisser tech
c'est le regret que j'ai c'est de pas
les avoir écrits tout seul comme moi
mais ça viendra peut-être bon l'olympia
c'est un monument ou quoi c'est c'est
quand même un sacré pareil vous ça vous
fait peur vous vous avez votre méthode
la fameuse méthode noah pour vous
préparer à cet olympia
ça m'excite beaucoup avant elle ça
m'excite beaucoup c'est c'est un
challenge important c'est ses traits la
barre est haute quoi c'est un endroit
qui a tellement d'histoires que je
respecte
c'est vrai que j'ai rêvé de cet endroit
et c'est demain quoi et j'aime bien là
ce que je suis en train de ressentir
depuis 48 heures la salle à cette
tension qui monte
j'aime beaucoup et ce rendez vous et les
servent à le faire je sais que vous
vivez un peu en france un peu au
cameroun un peu à new york
cette espèce de deux manières d'être un
peu partout en étant un peu nulle part
ça vous permet aussi de vous construire
ou c'est difficile au contraire je vis à
new york en fait ma base est vraiment à
new york et puis ensuite j'ai des
occupations ici est là et en particulier
en france où avec les associations les
enfants de la terre et fait l'amour avec
maman c'est vrai que il ya beaucoup de
travail très excitant ici et lorsque je
viens ici c'est vraiment pour pour
travailler et ensuite je retourne vers
mais megan à mes gosses qui sont à new
york
bon le cameroun c'est plus les vacances
maintenant c'est le centre de votre vie
maintenant les enfants non complètement
v4 les deux premiers qui sont l'âge
adolescence c'est un monde
un passage intéressant et excitant est
important et c'est quoi la méthode
d'éducation noah l'amour au maximum
j'essaie d'être le maximum et de l'est
c'est ce que je me savais que vous
exercez une certaine fascination que
c'est l'impression que tout ce que vous
faites ça marche
vous êtes consciente ce à travers une
sorte de une sorte de mythe en france
antilles tout ce qu'il a fait ça marche
bon c'est bien c'est grâce aux médias
j'imagine ce gars savent ou non de
l'ex-agent vous avez fait en sorte j'ai
aussi planté très souvent je me suis
planté très souvent mais je crois que
j'ai souvent essayé de relativiser ce
que les défaites et les victoires et je
prends du plaisir à faire ce que je fais
alors c'est vrai que le critère des fois
de succès ça peut être y en a qui vont
qui vont être malheureux en tant
qu'artiste parce qu'ils ont pas vendu
beaucoup
moi j'aime chanter donc forcément c'est
agréable et c'est bon succès
personnellement il est là quoi j'aime
faire ce que je fais et vous vous
économisez en même temps en france on
voit peu en france tout comme ça parce
que vous avez peur d'être trop accaparé
trop trop pris trop regarder non bon il
ya des forcément du moment où j'aime
bien être acteur de la vie
c'est intéressant d'être acteur c'est un
certain poids c'est une responsabilité
c'est une image ici et j'essaie d'en
faire quelque chose de positif et de
porter ce que je peux faire
donc affaire être utile et puis de temps
en temps il faut j'aime bien aussi de
cette spectateurs et dans ces moments-là
c'est vrai que j'aime bien l'anonymat
que j'ai donc dans une ville comme new
york et la vie au monde que je préfère
de ma soeur se soit pas l'animal sur la
scène de l'olympia
combien vous allez interpréter une
chanson mais on peut déjà se faire
beaucoup de choses sur le sur la soirée
ça dépend ça dépend de l'envié de
l'atmosphère ma foi on va jouer un bon
moment et puis on essaiera de partir et
laisser public un petit potion sa
tribune vous va jouer doit faire plaisir
je suis vraiment je vais en profiter au
maximum jeu on vous retrouvera 2 juillet
aussi à l'olympia bon et puis vous allez
faire une tournée dans un certain nombre
de grandes villes en région
oui on va jouer on va essayer de
continuer cette aventure qui accusait
d'avoir un fil à la patte quand même
vous êtes coincé j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'adore j'adore j'adore jouer j'adore la
scène c'est vraiment le bonheur pour
masala luxe que de pouvoir jouer de
pouvoir me produire avec mon groupe
c'est mon où ce sont mes meilleurs
copains et pour moi jouer ces cinq ados
quoi donc plus on joue mieux ce jeu est
signalé fait beau pour un mardi marie
claire noah votre moment où on cherche
midi éditeur c'est le très joli texte et
judas la chine et du tort qu'elle fait
beaucoup de choses également dans
l'association est avec vous merci
yannick noah redonne soir et demain soir
contre 1 quelques-uns à vous supporter
tout au long de ces six mois de
spectacles puis je rappelle ce disque
gagne pain merci voilà nous arriverons
là